pour faire rentrer de l'argent
l'entreprise line strauss-kahn va se
rabattre sur de petits épargnants
thierry line approche un couple de
retraités alain et sylvie hubac sous le
charme les époux your back confie aux
dirigeants de nouvelles escales les
économies de toute une vie et voilà
comment un million cent quarante mille
euros passe dans l'escarcelle de l essca
pendant que dominique strauss kahn jugé
dans la soie où ils sont dans la misère
et qu'ils ont été obligés d'emprunter
pour faire face à leurs
dépenses se sont retrouvés dans le
besoin du jour au lendemain incroyable
vous allez voir on a plein d'extraits de
ce cash investigations d'hier qui a fait
énormément parler aujourd'hui c'est une
star déferlement autour de cela on aura
peut-être d'ailleurs d'autres témoins
sachez le lundi dans l'émission pour le
moment on va en parler que florian
cynique et communicants politiques merci
la khl à florian c'est toujours un
plaisir de vous retrouver leur portable
est excellent à chaque fois et jean
missia fondateur de l'institut apollon
vous avez de nouvelles lunettes
crise
comme maintenant mais lunettes sont
blancs gilles verdez un port à me
traiter de raciste voilà la
[Musique]
connaissais pas du tout bah ouais
vous retrouvez d'ailleurs guillaume
genton il n'y a plus laissé nu est
blanche lui paraissait ça c'est vous qui
c'est vous qui le conseiller non mais
une copie un peu
c'est par amour
merci non mais c'est vrai jouet de
l'amour ici de gens merci d'être là en
tout cas quand la méchanceté devient
mensonge êtes vous d'accord avec le coup
de gueule de dsk contre france 2 c'est
vrai que hier c'est juste incroyable on
croyait je croyais pas que ça allait
aller aussi loin se cache investigations
on va revoir docsis d'autres
d'autres extraits mais voilà la réaction
de dsk quand la méchanceté devient
mensonge vos équipes de professionnels
auraient pu vérifier que je suis
résident fiscal marocain depuis 2013 et
que j'ai pas aimé impôts à hauteur de 23
8 % de mes bénéfices soit 800 12000
euros pour les années 2018 2019 2020 et
la réponse d'élise lucet
voilà qui ont indiqué que ce tweet de
dsk est une espèce d' amalgame nous
parlons de deux choses différentes et de
deux périodes différentes nous parlons
de l'impôt sur les sociétés de 2013 à
2018 il parle du fait qu'il est résident
fiscal marocain et avance des chiffres
sur les années postérieures de 2018 à
2020 alors c'est un petit peu technique
mais c'est vrai que on va vous montrer
des extraits que vous allez vraiment
comprendre comme nous tous un c'est vrai
ici après les scandales sexuels de dsk
qui l'ont éloigné du monde politique il
a décidé de créer sa société de conseil
et de conférenciers grâce à son énorme
réseau regarde
dsk fait comme d'anciens présidents
français et américain il devient
conférenciers
des pupitres sous les applaudissements
l'homme disserte sur l'économie mondiale
aux notes à bad brains la
gueule il distille ses bons conseils la
première remarque est le sujet des
médias mais en fait il ya de quoi douter
que dans la crise
un ex ministre des finances ex directeur
général du fmi mais qui plus est ex
présidentiable français un pedigree très
convoité partout sur la planète
alors quand la méchanceté devient
mensonge êtes vous d'accord avec le coup
de gueule de dsk contre france 2 s'il
vous plaît vous avez toutes vos clips en
kart wii guillaume jantes moi j'ai
trouvé ce reportage dégueulasse en fait
sous couvert dans quête de pseudo
enquête journalistique le message il est
très clair dsk selon cacher
investigations il n'a plus le droit de
travailler plus droit de rien faire de
sa vie depuis d'affaires nafissatou
diallo et puis comme d'habitude il ya
cette haine des riches qui est
insupportable la voix off s'étonne qui
voyage en business class pour aller
faire des conférences d'avis il veut pas
il va y aller en covoiturage enfin c'est
insupportable tout ça comme d'habitude
et une enquête à charge avec des
méthodes que je trouve plus que douteuse
ils se foutent de sa gueule il l'appelle
pour une faute contre une fausse
conférence pour lui demander ses prix je
trouve ça dégueulasse pour le service
public on allait regarder cette fausse
conférence regardez nous recevons ce
contrat
pour 45 minutes de discours il faut
débourser 70 mille euros hors taxes
auxquels il faut ajouter les billets
d'avion en business class sur la
compagnie de son choix
deux nuits en chambre suite dans un
hôtel là aussi de son choix
[Musique]
pour ce prix monsieur strauss kahn ne
donnera aucune interview
mais il nous fait l'honneur de
participer à notre dîner d'inauguration
mais ça il faut
gérer non en fait de dominique strauss
kahn il est plus humide des finances il
est plus au fmi et les plus
présidentiable il est plus un homme de
gauche d'ailleurs latine déjà est
vraiment donc en fait il fait ce qu'il
veut alors tout ce qu'il fait c'est
légal c'est peut-être pas moral on peut
trouver peut-être que c'est pas bien
peut-être que par exemple il doit
peut-être payé ses impôts en france
compte tenu que la france que la france
va apporter beaucoup mais en fait et
fait ce qu'il veut s'il a envie de faire
de l'optimisation fiscale au maroc il a
le droit effectivement on peut le
condamner d'un point de vue moral et
après là où je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec lui c'est qu'en fait on a
essayé de le joindre élise lucet a
essayé de le joindre il a toujours
décliné donc à un moment donné aussi
faut pas se plaindre du traitement qu'il
a reçu à charge il sait que ça va être
le cache à l'abri mais il vaut mieux
réparer banon était entendue et c'est
heureusement non maintenant vous
répondez pas pu me cache investigations
vous est le suivant d'amérique et de
jean michel bien sûr non tu dis c'est
trop cédé ses missions de façon ben oui
le propos éditoriale et déjà fait avant
qu'on commence en 4/3 qu'on sait que le
résultat final s'est achevée en font
c'est dsk même si dsk répond oui qui se
défend ça va tout s'en être anglo mére
tous a englouti dans une masse à charge
c'est sur le projet ce qui fait dsk
c'est le propre de tous les anciens
dirigeants tous de clinton à s'imposer
que ça ils font des conférences ils se
font rénumérés des centaines de milliers
de syriens vers 1h30
d'euros voilà y'a rien de honteux dans
tout ce qu'ils disent franchement même
mais j'en sais ils disent ils veulent
voyager en première classe ou si donc bs
cost mais l'économie
il a économisé 6 millions d'euros qu'il
aurait payé si jamais ils avaient été
fiscalisés en france pour sa société il
a pas payé il a fait cette économie là
en allant s'implanter au maroc on peut
on peut trouver aussi que c'est pas bien
alors même que le foot ce côté là ou
quoi j'ai regardé le dossier d'un corps
en entier
d'abord sur le couple de retraités l'aï
les apl même quoi il s'agit on le met
dans votre café je suis d'accord avec
vous mais vous téléphone et lors du
procès lorsque son associé des selleries
dit je ne verrai pas la société n'était
pas au courant et ruiné sa autre chose
toute sa fortune était fait avec qui
avec un dictateur d'un pays d'afrique
actu
j'en ai fait ça alors regardez sa
fortune avec sa toile à regarder
strauss-kahn vient hoyos et une vraie
présence ou pas fut un temps où il
habitait pratiquement là bas quand il
s'est installé au maroc il ne passait
pas un jour sans venir à oyo dominique
strauss kahn file donc le parfait amour
avec le président du concours
un personnage peu recommandable
l'empereur règne sans partage sur le
congo il a la mainmise sur la principale
richesse du pays l'or noir la majorité
des congolais n'a jamais bénéficié de
l'argent du pétrole
le régime est régulièrement accusée des
pires exactions actes de torture
répression politique
arrestations arbitraires
et ce qu'il veut ah oui alors quoi
mathieu manon mais c'est vraiment
vraiment bravo à cette enquête kodak et
l'expérience qui disait inorganisés il
disait géraldine est là elle a bien me l
a dit et ce qu'il veut sur ces
conférences il veut demander sur soi
bien son pays
sait pas trop si sa décision inquiète il
n'a pas le droit de dire ce dont c'est
parce que tout ça est désuet à charge
sur les enquêtes effectivement qu'ils
prennent sens 150000 euros 200 mille
euros quant à des enquêtes et pour
conseiller et rimbaud de l'optimisation
fiscale et société là dessus je n'ai
rien à dire c'est un homme brillant qui
gagne son argent comme ça sarkozy le
fait
il parle pas l'anglais qui n'est pas le
bon et qui n'est pas très demandée au
volant d'éloignement déchets désolée
pour ton ami mais c'est nous tous ceux
qui sont bilingues sont très bien ça ça
me dérange pas c'est l autre partie où
j'ai hallucinant des conseillers sur top
chef un hollande a
cédé en cours
vernet mais c'est alors là gilles verdez
tient alors là là oui pour une fois où
comme souvent je suis en désaccord avec
vous mais moi je suis pas un mois que
j'aime pas leurs noms mais non il lui
fit la part du fesf et la page je fais
la part de la raison je sais que sur les
conférences il fait ce qu'il veut quand
on est demandé si vous demandez 70 mille
100 me si les gens lui donne après sur
le réduire à quatre à vienne sur le sur
les grottes très longtemps ça c'est
d'adn ainsi pu s'allumer faux mais il
faut mener l'enquêté pour ça qu'on est
en train de mener l enquête jeudi et on
aura peut-être ces personnes
prochainement sur le bateau pour en
savoir un petit peu à une formidable
mais moi je suis en désaccord total sur
son coup de gueule parce que sont google
son tweet ravageur là c'est insensé il
est appelé plein de fois il a appelé
plein de fois il a la possibilité de
s'exprimer et il fait un tweet que je
juge vraiment immonde et qui mêle des
tas de choses fausses et il n'a pas le
droit de réduire les
coûts il ne peut pas nous il n'a en
aucun cas bien sûr en aucun cas
n'importe quoi là mais moi je ne suis
pas du tout fan de l'émission et je
rejoins effectivement de mathieu hier on
appris des choses si tout ça est vrai
assez sérieux parce que notamment ce qui
m'a choqué c'est le couple de retraités
on va essayer ils m'ont fait une panne
immense ont essayé par désiré parce que
il ya aussi quatre ans de négocier la
dette pour le combo apparemment là il a
falsifié des documents du fmi si c'est
vrai ça c'est dramatique la main sachant
qu'il était président des ja m et donc
vous vous êtes vous vous trouvez qu'ils
ont exagéré sur dsk où vous trouvez que
dsk vous croyez à tout ce qui a été dit
non moi je trouve que la tonalité
générale du document était
était un peu à charge effectivement donc
là vous êtes rencontre on voit par
exemple l'interview que fait élise lucet
avec l'avocat son ami avocat là je sais
plus comment il s'appelle qui était qui
est un bureau sur les champs-elysées là
c'est insupportable ils ont une maison
des méthodes cash aérien qui est
insupportable indépendamment de ça moi
je suis tout à fait d'accord enfin que
les gens gagnent leur vie comme ils
veulent sans faire rien d'illégal moi
j'ai pas de soucis avec sa part contre
moi j'ai un soucis avec l'éthique du
personnage 1 parce que c'est quand même
faut rappeler le parcours de deux mille
choses moi je le connais très bien ce
que je lis en prof à l'université
pendant trois ans ouais et j'ai même
fait un troisième cycle avec lui à
l'université de nanterre donc c'est
quelqu'un que je connais depuis très
longtemps que j'ai suivi ensuite on se
dit dans ses activités et je trouve que
cette espèce de celle ou celui qui nous
a été présenté comme un peu le
représentant d'une gauche sociale qui
fait qui a passé des années à faire la
morale aux classes populaires et cetera
en réalité c'est une c'est un personnage
qui se savait rage id qui s'avère
comment dirais-je normes et règles
connaisseurs mais non non vous le
connaissez donc la dent de ce qui est
dit dans ce non ce dont ce reportage
est-ce que vous en aviez déjà entendu
parler wade a découvert des choses
gg oui oui donc sur la société l essca
et le couple de retraités jeu de ça
évidemment je sais quelque chose qui que
seule la plainte qui a été déposée
à l'hermine et même l'afrique malawi
mais là c'est pareil c'est bien sûr que
à les conseiller un dictateur
sanguinaire cessé mais c'est pas bien ça
même en même temps le dictateur
sanguinaire il n'est pas là que je
strauss kahn quand strauss kahn va le
quitter et va aller voir ailleurs la
laisser le problème du congo et sa
dictature resteront donc il faut pas
tout mélanger mais moi je crois
qu'effectivement le rythme si riche le
pti le vip le type qui qui promeut
l'universalisme par l'immigrationnisme
qui va lui s'installer dans des paradis
fiscaux kiki qui veut bien que le peuple
son peuple historique soit envahi et que
lui va s'isoler dans des grandes villes
à marrakech soigneusement gardés par des
murailles ça c'est insupportable que le
problème c'est pas un problème de
légalité encore qu'il ya une enquête en
cours qui qu'il appartiendra de
démontrer s'il a commis des choses
illégales ou pas le problème c'est un
problème de moralité par rapport à ce
personnage
qui a été directeur du fmi qui a donc
prodiguer des conseils à des états
pauvres de restructuration de leur dette
qui était ministre des finances en
france qui a dont certains d'ailleurs
disait qui serait un excellent président
de la république française sans oublier
en 2012 les mêmes d'ailleurs qui
viennent nous expliquer aujourd'hui que
zemmour serait une catastrophe aller
contre la tentation vous reste donc
c'est moi d'ailleurs mais donc donc
voilà bah moi c'est ça c'est avec sar
j'ai un problème
vous restez si
vous voulez merci théo l'avant plaisir
bon ça c'est florian si nicky vous êtes
communiquant en politique est-ce que ça
c'est des choses qu'on on savait ou pas
du tout est ce que vous avez qu'est-ce
que vous avez procédure reportage c'est
à charge abbas et par un reportage c'est
une exécution médiatique en règle sur le
service public il ya plusieurs
difficultés à mon sens d'abord à ce
stade ce reportage ils ne montrent rien
qui puisse légalement être reproché à
dominique strauss kahn la justice elle a
jusque là été saisis elle s'est déjà
prononcé sur les royaumes pour ce qu'il
reste à ce stade sur ls cas il y à une
instruction qui déterminera les
responsabilités mais à ce stade ce que
fait élise lucet s'est érigé le soupçon
médiatique sur cet homme qui n'est plus
un personnage public est aujourd'hui un
homme d'affaires tentait de démontrer
comme elle le fait qu'au fond dans ses
actes il ferait le contraire de ce qu'il
a prodigués dans ses discours politique
pendant des années pourquoi pas elle est
élise lucet une très grande spécialiste
et une très grande donneuse de leçons
moi je rappelle qu élise lucet est la
journaliste la plus mise en examen en
france parce que elle est la spécialiste
de la fausse information régulièrement
elles se trompent régulièrement elle
dénigre hab régulièrement elle dit femme
mais elle s'en fout parce que au fond ce
qui compte pour elle c'est non pas de
faire de l'information et du
divertissement à l'âge ajoutait elle a
été mise en examen plusieurs fois oui
oui c'est la journaliste qui l'a pas
mise en examen et convient
de vérifier ce que la justice dira dans
chacune de ses instructions par ailleurs
au fond elle est la spécialiste pour
dénoncer les gros salaires etc il
faudrait donner le sien au fond quand on
gagne plus de 25000 euros par mois eh
bien je crois qu'on peut s'abstenir de
faire la leçon à la démagogie
des mazery d'emplois n'a roulé sur la
morale à combien de showkhi bien sûr à
chaque fois chaque semaine il rebondir
tu peux sur disque dit flo qui lisent et
pourquoi on ferait pas un jouet préfet
pas un cache un message
sur élise lucet sur france télévisions
mais voilà j'en ai dépenses de prendre
télévision bah oui il faut ajouter c'est
un service public en même temps donc
c'est donc un service spécialisé de
l'état pour ça vous fait est-ce que par
ailleurs il est normal que l'on se soit
intéressé autant à dominique strauss
kahn alors qu'il ya dans les pandora
paper plus de 600 français qui cache des
sommes pharaoniques bien plus importante
que
chacun alors oui et nous on nous dira ce
qu'il en pense ce reportage et il est
accompagné de dessins qui sont à la fois
antisémites et particulièrement salaces
alors ce sont ces mêmes personnes qui
toute la journée nous donne des leçons
d'éthique journalistique
critique tous les autres formats en
disant qu'au fond on mélange le
divertissement et c'est quoi ça ça c'est
profondément dégueulasse parce qu'au
fond ça représente un homme ça fait
référence évidemment à ce qu'il est dans
sa vie professionnelle dans sa vie
privée puis au fond ça sous-entend tout
au long du reportage qu'il est un
pervers et que donc tout ce qu'il fait
c'est mal et moi je crois que cela c'est
une erreur de traitement on aurait pu
faire la même chose d'une autre manière
et on aurait au moins aussi bien informé
les journalistes sont des têtes à
claques c'est insupportable c'est nous
lancée alors c'est la liga tarn assument
des journalistes internationaux qui ont
alerté france 2 en me disant le seul nom
français qui apparaît dans les fans de
rappeurs ccc
c'est
fou mais j'ai pas le seul sur les 6,3 à
hauteur de 1 à 3 effectivement qui sont
apparus mais les autres en fait ceux qui
ont placé de l'argent notamment dans la
société elle est ce cas ils sont pour le
moins sulfureux dont qui tiennent pas
nécessairement non plus à apparaître
d'ailleurs ils n'ont pas porté plainte
il n'y a eu que trois plaintes de
déposées contre l'esca parce que les
autres les oligarques russes les
dictateurs africains et ses soutiens ne
vont pas se mouiller en portant plainte
pour arriver devant la lumière ni d'un
point là dessus aussi j'entends
dominique strauss kahn quel [ __ ] il
est allé au soudan au sud-soudan quel
[ __ ] il est allé restructurer la dette
du congo mais est ce qu'il est illégal
d'aller dans ces pays non est ce qu'il
est immoral d'aller dans ces pays en
question mais moi j'ai attire
l'attention c'est une quête à turin en
tiendrait compte dans ces deux langues
question amont et si tu me laisses
terminé tu seras pourquoi tout
simplement parce que est ce qu on
reprocherait à un médecin qui soigne les
populations locales d'aller là-bas aidc
pos place en régie chez elle de mettre
en place un système financier de ces
pays mais moi je ne le comprends mais
charge sur laquelle à la question la
menace est une question de cohérence
c'est à dire vous pouvez pas prêcher une
homélie sociale pendant des années
culpabiliser les français pendant des
années par rapport à l'argent par
rapport en leur demandant de s'unir et
réalisé par l'immigration kick et qui
enrichit et en même temps vous ai bien
avoir un comportement exactement inverse
c'est-à-dire pratiques et
l'universalisme des preuves d'aider des
paradis fiscaux c'est à dire avoir une
cupidité sans limite pour le pognon
c'est pas illégal je suis d'accord avec
vous mais c'est immoral voilà c'est une
question de cohérence des coins respecte
la règle qu'on va vite j'ai eu je
pensais qu'ils étaient manipulés par les
étrangers mais en fait non il y à aussi
l'argent et donc tu tous les jaloux tu
es frustré pas du tout
si on n'a pas dû lui que tu as le droit
d'avoir ce n'est pas une information à
tu sais moi j'en ai g j'ai aucun
problème avec l'argent et mon but c'est
pas tout le monde se paupérise pour que
pour être de gauche moi je veux tout le
pognon pour que tout le monde soit
heureux moi j'ai pas de problème avec ça
par contre je peux dire que j'ai un
problème avec l'incohérence voilà avec
l'incohérence
lunettes et tous et des frais tout
je tends vers la peinture s'achète
attendent que je sais les chin d'aflou
c'était
monsieur oui oui après
jean en fait la finesse est de ton anaïs
et pas du tout ce qu'il ya dans le
reportage le reportage c'est un
reportage à charge qui dit poids qui dit
dsk est un pervers qui fait des
raccourcis et les amalgames dégueulasse
quand il dit qu'il va au congo
conseiller un homme un dictateur dans un
pays dans lequel on pratique la torture
il ya un raccourci qui est dégueulasse
sanctionne la clôture savoir qu'est ce
que tu crois que les conseils du fmi le
font tous les jours je trouve nommé
geler leurs effets d'ici là il à 190
final un traitement choc que les
caricatures n'ont pas leur place dans ce
genre de reportage la voix off on dirait
une veuve de bêtises ils sont des
parodies face à la menace en mai des
services pas l'accord sur la forme